[Music]
that's homework you already hand it in
good job you're so fun I write now you
just oh wait why would I say that I just
what are you talking about yeah why
would you say that I just looked into
you I just looked into your eyes and I
saw kittens in hot-air-balloon yeah
taking a ride I'm not judging you this
is a our own company we get to do
whatever we want
Jeff Ross isn't here yeah where's he
he's off he's off finding soup on a
mission and because a certain person
found out that a certain boss isn't
around a certain person dropped a couple
of tabs of some sweet mama Jane is that
what you guys call it there's no what
you kids call it I know what you kids
call it I know the lingo he took some
Bennie's some poppers some yellow
Bellinis yellow blini he did you took
one of your greens submarines and went
for a ride down under I know what
happens don't try and fool me on the
lingo kids I know you're all doing onion
shots backstage what's that we ready to
go doing my thing right now a little fun
for a change
Jackie Mason isn't here we might as well
loosen things up a bit
you know what happens when he goes home
he goes home to his bedroom and he
stands behind a podium true even when he
sleeps on his bed there's a podium in
front of him scraps that no one will
understand except they'll know this
guy's high as a kite
[Music]
you